natural language processing is becoming
more and more convenient providing
better consumer experiences and
automating touch points for business but
ai for business is very different than
consumer ai
ai for business needs to understand the
language of business while working to
minimize unintended biases so how can
you establish unbiased ai for business
let's find out with this edition of the
ai training ground
in consumer technology there are a host
of voice ai apps redefining the way we
experience services and purchase
products there are also business
applications such as speech recognition
to help court reporters produce records
of trial proceedings and tools that
allow physicians to dictate clinical
notes
however natural language processing is
only as good as its accuracy and that
accuracy depends on how well the ai is
trained
and if the models are being built with
the end user in mind and without
specific inherent biases for example if
an ai model is only trained using white
males under 40 for voice recognition
data or doesn't use men and women with
varied vocal registries as part of the
data sets the ai model will be biased
from the start and this leads to
error-laden results that undermine the
ai's usefulness and prevent it from
being inclusive to all another factor in
avoiding potential biases in natural
language processing comes from the
diversity of languages being used during
model training for example some models
convert all languages to english and
then back to the language of interest if
you translate she is a nurse from
english to turkish and then back to
english it reads she is a lady
even worse if you do the same with he is
a nurse the english to turkish back to
english translation reads she is a lady
yet again this is because there's
important grammatical context that's
lost and it results in inaccuracy and in
this case gender bias making sure your
ai is accurate and unbiased starts with
using the right data with appropriate
diversity for model training and
continuously monitoring to guard against
drift will ensure you have trustworthy
explainable ai outcomes
learn more about implementing
trustworthy and unbiased ai with ibm's
ai training ground
[Music]
you